but first we have with us two local
admin who started their own t-shirt
company Tim Kremlin and Sam Dube welcome
thanks for having us on the show Nadine
and we watched you all the time oh
thanks now not like it not like in a
stalker way because yeah you know it's
not like a person who's like obsessed
yeah it's not tell us about the t-shirts
well it seems like everywhere you go
these days you see t-shirts with Detroit
slogans up
you said it Tim you may be familiar with
Detroit verse everybody just the best
and Detroit hustles harder you can't
beat it you sure can't which is why
we're proud to present to you our very
own t-shirt d2 roids and we'd like to
thank our crew members Lea and Tommy
pencils for modeling our d2 Roy t-shirts
today
take it easy on Tommy he's a little
nervous he's not used to being in front
of the camera for a change I gotta be
honest guys I don't get it it looks like
you put a to where the T should be no it
not looks like that's what we did
yeah so now it's d2 Roy the Pugh roids
but why well ask that can best be
explained by a freestyle rap performed
by Leah and Tommy pencils sounds like
fun
Leah Tommy pencils take it away if
you're in the market for a cool t-shirt
if you're in the market for a cool
t-shirt is this life yes this is live
but on a commercial break
why don't we move on oh you can do it
yeah lead him in again Leah if you're in
the market for a cool t-shirt
[Applause]
[Laughter]